because the sweetest temperament he's
really from welcoming baby Archie to
their struggles with the British press I
won't be putting into into into playing
a game that's they killed my mom
2019 has been a rollercoaster year for
making Marco and Prince Harry and were
breaking down all of their highs and
lows the last time I was here I
suggested of course to someone no the
year started off strong with a pregnant
Megan beaming everywhere she went she
has told friends that this is the most
exciting the happiest period in her life
in February the Dutchess of Sussex
jetted off to New York for a
star-studded baby shower thrown by
besties Serena Williams it was a very
very small private affair and just a
very special time for her Gayle King
Amal Clooney Abigail Spencer Jessica
Maroney and Nisha nunu were amongst the
celebs in attendance a good time was had
by all that's what I'll say next Megan
and Harry were off to Morocco for a
three-day tour centered around causes
they hold near and dear including
highlighting girls education and youth
empowerment in April they said goodbye
to Kensington Palace for their newly
renovated Frogmore cottage and on May 6
we finally got the surprise we'd all
been waiting for
this morning watching Harry deliver the
happy news to reporters was literally
everything I haven't been in many of us
this is definitely my first but bears
amazing
the couple introduced archie harrison to
the world two days later with the
televised appearance from inside windsor
castle magic it's pretty amazing
one month later meghan made her first
public appearance since giving birth
looking radiant at the queen's trooping
the colours birthday celebration Meghan
wanted to really mirror the Duchess of
Cambridge's maternity leave the Duchess
Cambridge was out after the births of
Prince George and Princess Charlotte
Prince Louie just weeks after for
trooping but by late June Meghan in here
e were parting ways with William and
Kate and the royal foundation to create
Sussex royal okay the last thing you
disagreed on how to resolve it in
addition to the split in charities there
were also ongoing discussions about
disentangling the finances and a
reinvigorated debate about a rift
between the two couples but the
sisters-in-law were all smiles on July
13th as they cheered on Serena Williams
at Wimbledon
[Music]
and love was in the air at the UK
premiere of The Lion King the red carpet
marked Megan's first since joining the
ranks of motherhood and was a topic she
and Beyonce seemed to bond over
another hi and first for the Duchess was
guest editing the September issue of
British Vogue but I love their
complicity to make this secret project
such an example of collaboration
together and inclusiveness the 38 year
old mom opened up about the forces for
change issue in a heartfelt editor's
letter quote I was about five months
pregnant when this process began and by
the time you hold this issue in your
hands my husband and I will be holding
our three-month-old baby boy in ours
it's a very special time for me
personally on so many levels I never
thought my life would be that awesome
but things took a bit of a turn in
August when details of the Duchess's
38th birthday trip to Ibiza and the
South of France were revealed including
the couple's use of private jets Elton
John quickly came to their defense
tweeting after a hectic year continuing
their hard work and dedication to
charity David and I wanted the young
family to have a private holiday inside
the safety and tranquility of our home
to maintain a high level of much-needed
protection we provided them with a
private jet ellen degeneres also had
their backs calling them the most
down-to-earth and compassionate people
hi everyone thank you so much for being
here today
September 12th marked another high for
the Royals when Meghan officially ended
her maternity leave to launch her smart
set capsule collection in collaboration
with smart works community is going
through your closet and saying this is
the blazer that I wore when I nailed my
first job interview and got my dream job
and I don't need that anymore because
I'm where I want to be but if I'm able
to share that blazer and be part of
another woman's success story then
that's community
next on this Essex's agenda was their
ten-day tour of Africa which came
complete with its own set of ups and
downs
the Royals danced their way into the
hearts of South Africans I want you to
know that for me I am here with you as a
mother as a wife as a woman as a woman
of color and as your sister they gushed
about each other as parents and shared
some sweet PDA moments we even got in
Archie citing Archie behaved perfectly
on his first official engagement he
gurgled he giggles but after several
days of glowing press the sixes dropped
a bombshell announcing that they were
suing the Mail on Sunday after they
published a handwritten letter Meghan
wrote to her estranged father and when
the documentary Harry and Meghan in
African journey aired several weeks
later we saw just how much the constant
media scrutiny had been affecting the
couple over the last year not many
people have asked if I'm okay but it's
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes making Harry
and Archie are spending the final part
of 2019 taking some much-needed family
time out of the spotlight and we're
hoping to see them come back stronger
than ever in 2020